THE EXPLOSION OF TEMU:
By now, I’m sure most of you have heard
about Temu. They’re the sketchy online retailer
that sells counterfeits and unbelievably cheap
items. If you’re not familiar with Temu, just
take a look at what happens if you look up Apple
Watch on Temu. You get all these results that only
cost $10 to $25 and that’s not just for the band,
it’s for the entire watch itself. It’s the
same thing if you look up Apple Airpods. You
get a bunch of knockoffs that are as cheap as $4.
Obviously, these counterfeits don’t quite stack
up to the real deal but for the price, they’re
actually insane. Oftentimes, you can’t even tell
which one is fake and which one is real even when
they’re side by side. It’s not just electronics
that are cheap on Temu either. Everything from
shows and sweatshirts to power tools and pet
supplies can be found for ridiculously cheap
prices on Temu. And if you think all of this
seems too good to be true, well then, it’s because
it is. The only reason Temu is able to sell all
of these items for so cheap is because they take a
massive loss on each and every item sold. In fact,
according to Wired, Temu is losing an average
of $30 on every single order which added up
to a total loss of over $3 billion last year.
And I think now would be a good time to mention
that Temu wasn’t even launched till September
of 2022. So, they haven’t even been in business
for 18 months at this point, and they’re burn
rate is already over $3 billion per year. But,
there is method behind all the madness.
Thanks to Temu’s promotional prices,
they’ve exploded in popularity. Within a matter
of 18 months, they’ve been able to take on Amazon
and all the other physical retailers go from 0
to 89th most visited website within the US and
148th most visited website in the world pulling
in over 400 million visits every single month.
For perspective, they rank higher than established
media outlets like Fox Business, NBC News, CNBC,
and AP News. And that’s just their website.
Temu is often the most downloaded app within
the US on both the iOS app store and the
Google Play Store in any given month. So,
who exactly are the people behind Temu, and
will they actually be able to make it to
the other side, or are these losses gonna
end up killing them from the inside out.
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS:
Taking a look back,
the story of Temu takes us back to a middle class
Chinese man named Colin Huang or Huang Zheng.
Colin was born in Zhejiang, China on January 1,
1980 to two factory workers. As you could guess,
Colin really didn’t start off with much and he
would follow the path of any hard working Asian
immigrant. He would study his butt off and get
into one of the most prestigious universities
in China: Zhejiang University where he majored in
computer science. From there, he would turn around
and attend the University of Wisconsin, where he
would obtain a masters in computer science. This
background allowed him to score internships at
Microsoft and Google and receive job offers from
several top tier tech companies including
Microsoft, Oracle, IBM, and Google who at
the time was just a small startup. But, on the
recommendation of one of his friends/mentors,
William Ding who is a multi deca billionaire
today himself, Colin would end up joining Google
as a full time software engineer at Google in
2004. This would turn out to be a brilliant
move as Google would go public that same year
and they would reach a $100 billion market cap
just 1 year later. This meant that Colin’s stock
compensation went to the moon and he would become
a multi millionaire in his mid 20s. For most Asian
immigrants, this is where the arc would naturally
come to a conclusion. From here, they would
just work up the corporate ladder into the upper
echelons of management and executive leadership,
and that would pretty much be it. But, Colin would
become part of a growing group of Asian immigrants
who were interested in bringing American tech back
home to China. Technically, this was actually his
official job at Google itself. He was supposed
to help Google with their expansion into China,
but this didn’t work out all that well as Google
wasn’t really able to compete against Chinese
giants like Baidu. Colin saw the writing on the
wall by 2007 and he would leave Google to create
his own e commerce startup called Ouku in China.
Ouku was just you’re run of the mill e commerce
electronics shop. Thanks to how big the interente
is, Ouku was able to achieve moderate success
in the millions of dollars but it didn’t even
hold a candle against real giants like Alibaba,
JD.com, and Tencent. As such, Colin would end up
flipping Ouku for $2.2 million in 2010 and start
looking for a new angle within the e commerce
market. This sort of spiritual journey ended
up taking multiple years and one point he even
considered moving back to the United States and
just opening a tech hedge fund. But eventually,
he would find his unique angle in 2015 thanks to
the rise of mobile social media. Colin noticed
that there were massive online retailers like
Amazon and Alibaba and massive social media giants
like Facebook and Tencent, but there was no one
who was trying to do both at the same time. And
this would end up being the unique spin he would
integrate into his new ecommerce business in 2015.
The goal of this business was to gamify shopping
like never before by combining the most addictive
parts of shopping and the most addictive parts
of social media and he would call it Pinduoduo.
MAKING A NAME:
Pinduoduo was exactly the e-commerce breakthrough
that Colin was looking for that could take on
the Chinese giants? What did Pinduoduo do that
was so unique you ask? Well, like Temu, it offered
rock bottom prices but instead of the price being
subsidized by Pinduoduo, it was subsidized
by scale. For example, users might see an ad
about how they could get groceries like fruits and
vegetables for half the price. There was just one
catch. To get the groceries for half the price,
you needed to recruit 50 or a 100 people to buy it
with you. The more people you recruited, the lower
the price. And given that Pinduoduo wasn’t selling
smartphones and computers or something, and
instead selling simple cheap everyday goods that
everybody needed, it was quite easy to recruit
people because the ask was so small and straight
forward. You could share it with your friends and
family or the people in your apartment or your
classmates and colleagues. Together, you could all
save 25 or 50% on everyday goods, and on the flip
side, Pinduoduo just got 50 or a 100 repeating
customers by advertising to just one person. And
that’s just the first cycle, imagine what happens
when each of those 50 people tell 50 more people.
The network effect simply becomes ridiculous and
that’s exactly what happened. Before you knew it,
Pinduoduo would become a sizeable player within
the Chinese e-commerce market. As of 2023,
they stood at 17.4% market share across the
country. And Colin would simply fuel this
fire with practices that he learned from Google.
For example, instead of trying to pay engineers
as little as possible, he would pay them 30%
more than they would earn at Alibaba and 60%
more than they would earn at JD.com. Also, instead
of hiring candidates with decades of experience,
Colin would hire fresh college graduates who
were hungry for success. And I think this chart
tells you everything you need to know regarding
what happened next. Pinduoduo would essentially
grow from 0 to $18 billion worth of annual revenue
within a matter of 6 years. And it was from this
mountain top that Colin would launch Temu. The
concept behind Temu is extremely simple. It’s no
secret that basically all the listings on Amazon
and Shopify are just highly marked up low quality
goods from China, and people are not only starting
to notice but they’re getting frustrated. Why pay
$20 for something that you can get for $5 on
Alibaba? Atleast then, the quality will match
the price. There’s only one problem with this
logic though. The average westerner isn’t familiar
with Alibaba or Aliexpress. All they know is that
their Amazon purchases are shit, and that’s were
Temu comes in. Temu’s main goal has been to bridge
this knowledge gap and show people that they can
buy the same stuff they get on Amazon for way
cheaper. Now, I should mention that Alibaba has
been trying to do this with Aliexpress since 2010,
but let’s just say that Alibaba never understood
social media the same way that Temu does which
brings us into Temu’s brilliant launch strategy.
MARKET DOMINATION:
Temu’s strategy was actually
extraordinarily simple. Instead of spending
millions on Google ads or influencer sponsorships,
Temu decided to spend millions on brilliantly
positioned giveaways. Temu basically went out
and purchased thousands if not tens of thousands
of legitimate products that westerners wanted like
Nintendo Switches. They didn’t just straight
up give these away though. If they had just
run a giveaway, no one would’ve batted an eye. It
would’ve just been seen as an obvious promotional
event. Instead, what Temu did was price these
products at ridiculously low prices. For example,
they offered the Switch for $7. All of a sudden,
Temu was able to create an insane amount of
mystery and intrigue as to what was going on
here. Is it a scam? Is it a counterfeit? Were
these units stolen? You know, all those normal
natural questions. As such, 99.99% of the people
who saw this probably chuckled and moved on. But
0.01% thought: hey this is probably a scam but
it’s only $7. I’ll just use my burner PayPal
account to pay for it. If I get it, I get it,
if I don’t, I don’t. And to their surprise,
they actually end up receiving the Switch,
and it’s not a counterfeit or stolen unit
either, it’s straight up legit. This only
has to happen to a few hundred people before it
becomes international headlines and millions of
people are talking about it on social media.
And that’s exactly what happened. Honestly,
credit to Temu for running such a genius marketing
campaign. In terms of the ratio between exposure
and dollars spent, this was probably one of the
best campaigns in history. Basically overnight,
hundreds of millions of people now knew about
Temu. And when they check out the website or app,
they’ll see that they can’t quite get a $7 Switch
every day of the week, but they can get products
that are way cheaper than on Amazon or American
retailers, and naturally a lot of people are quite
interested. And honestly, I think that’s great
because it’s about time that we stop overpaying
for junk on Amazon and dropshipping stores.
In terms of the viability of Temu, normally,
burning $3 billion per year would be an extremely
dangerous game to play even with a bunch of VC
capital. But, luckily for Temu, they’re backed
by the giant that is Pinduoduo who is currently
worth $128 billion. So, it’s highly likely that
Temu is here to stay and they’re only gonna grow
in popularity. With that being said though, if
you’re gonna buy on Temu, you should be wary of
2 things. Number 1, Temu is not a scam but they do
have terrible customer support because the entire
platform is essentially just a bunch of Chinese
factories and warehouses that don’t really care
about the customer experience. So, it’s definitely
a possibility that your order get’s lost and you
have no recourse. So, definitely be careful about
how much you spend on Temu and what exactly you
buy. And as for number 2? Well, I’m not trying
to stereotype here, but Temu is almost certainly
installing spyware, malware, tracking a bunch
of your data, and who knows what else. In fact,
Pinduoduo was removed from the Google Play Store
for exactly those reasons. With that being said
though, if it’s not Temu that’s tracking you,
it’s gonna be Google, Facebook, and all the
other American tech giants. So, it’s really up to
you as to whether you’re ok with a Chinese company
doing the same thing. But either way, this is only
the beginning of Temu and Chinese tech in general
and it’s only gonna get crazier from here. TikTok
has already started implementing some brilliant
strategies to ensure that they never get banned
from the US. Check out this video to learn more.